something that I'm obsessed with lately
is this notion of overt versus covert
contracts right there are overt
contracts where you exchange work for
money or you exchange any number of
things in an overt way but then there
are covert contracts um and those take
on a very different form and always lead
to uh in my belief bad things well how
much of human and chimp relationships
are over versus covert well here's one
thing that we know is true
dogs and humans the dog to human
relationship is 100 overt they don't
manipulate you now you could say they do
in the sense that they learn that if
they look a certain way or roll on their
back they get food but there's no
um there's no banking of that behavior
for a future date where then they are
going to undermine you and take your
position okay so in that sense dogs can
be a little bit manipulative in some
sense but
um now okay so overt contract
would be
we both want to do some work together
we're going to make some money you get X
percentage I get X percentage it's overt
covert contract
which is in my opinion bad always bad
would be we're gonna do some work
together you're gonna get a percentage
of money I'm gonna get a percentage of
money
could look just like the overt contract
but secretly I'm resentful that I got
the percentage I got
so what I start doing is
covertly taking something else what do I
take maybe I take the opportunity to jab
you verbally every once in a while maybe
I take the opportunity to show up late
maybe I take the opportunity to get to
know one of your co-workers so that I
might start a business with them that's
covert Contracting and you see this
sometimes in romantic relationships one
person we won't set the male or female
in any direction here and just say
it's I'll make you feel powerful if you
make me feel desired okay great there's
nothing explicitly wrong about that
contract if they both know and they both
agree but what if it's I'll do that but
I'll have kids with you so you feel
powerful you'll have kids with me so I
feel desired but secretly I don't want
to do that
or they one person says I don't want to
do that or both don't so what they end
up doing is saying okay so I expect
something else I expect you to do
certain things for me or I expect you to
pay for certain things for me covert
contracts are the signature of
everything bad overt contracts are the
signature of all things good yeah and I
think about this a lot because I've seen
a lot of examples of this I've
like anyone we participate in these
things whether or not we want to or not
and the thing that gets transacted the
most
is
well I should say the things that get
transacted the most are the overt things
you'll see money
um time
sex
um property
whatever happens to be information but
what ends up happening is that when
people I believe don't feel safe they
feel threatened in some way like it's
they don't feel safe in a certain
interaction what they do is they start
taking something else
while still engaging in in the exchange
and I'll tell you
if there's one thing about human nature
that's bad it's that
feature why that feature or is it a
bugger feature as you Engineers like to
say
um I think it's because we were
allocated a certain extra amount of
prefrontal Cortex that makes us more
sophisticated than a dog
more sophisticated than a chimpanzee but
they do it too and
it's because it's often harder
to deal with
in the short term to deal with the real
sense of this is scary this feels
threatening than it is to play out all
the iterations it takes a lot of brain
work to you're playing chess and go
simultaneously trying to figure out
where things are going to end up and we
just don't know so it's a way I think of
creating a false sense of certainty but
I'll tell you covert contracts the only
certainty is that it's going to end
badly the question is how badly
conversely overt contracts always end
well
always the problem with overt contracts
is that you can't be certain that the
other person is not engaging in a covert
contract you can only take
responsibility for your own Contracting
well one of the challenges of being
human is looking at another human being
and figuring out
the way their way of being their
behavior which of the two types of
contracts it represents because they
look awfully the same on the surface and
one of the one of the challenges of
being human is the decision we all make
is are you somebody that takes a leap of
trust and trusts other humans and are
willing to take the hurt are you going
to be uh cynical and skeptical and avoid
most interactions until they're uh they
over a long period of time prove your
trust yeah I never liked the phrase
history repeats itself
um when it comes to humans because it
doesn't apply if the people or the
person is actively working to resolve
their own flaws I do think that if
people are willing to do dedicated
introspective work go into their
subconscious
do the hard work have hard conversations
and get better at hard conversations
something that I'm constantly trying to
get better at I think people can change
but they have to want to change it does
seem like deep down we all can kind of
tell the difference between over and
covert like we have a good sense I think
one of the benefits of having this
characteristic of Mind where I value
loyalty I've been extremely uh fortunate
to spend most of my life in overt
relationships and I think that creates a
really fulfilling life